hallo herzlich willkommen in meine taten
meldet heute gibt es von mir ein
weiteres typisches rezept ich war heute
abschnitt es sind kleine hefeteig
taschen oder hefeteig brötchen und wenn
ihr wissen wollt wie man die macht dann
bleibt jetzt dran
ihr braucht 500 gramm mehl einen
teelöffel vanille zucker einen teelöffel
salz ein halbe würfel hefe eine halbe
packung backpulver zwei eier und davon
habe ich ein eigelb jetzt zur seite
gelegt dass wir die spieler zum
bestreichen benutzen
150 gramm joghurt mit 1,5 aber das ist
auch nicht so wichtig 150 milliliter
lauwarme milch und 50 gramm
da habe ich jetzt geschmacksneutrale
sonnenblumenöl benutzt und aus diesen
zutaten knetet jetzt einen selbst
weichen hefeteig trocken sagt die hefe
noch rein und löst die ein bisschen auf
und jetzt kommen alle anderen zutaten
mit dieses eigelb bleibt weg
gebt ihr noch mal ein schuss olivenöl
mit dazu es kommt nämlich immer auch auf
die eier größe darauf an und muss weiter
sein als ganz normaler hefeteig
die hand dann gut einfetten dann geht
der teig auch nicht so auf einer hand
fest weniger gut durchgeknetet habt es
damit den ganzen tag zu einer kugel
zusammen
kneten jetzt einmal noch auf der
arbeitsfläche durch die fed ich aber
vorher ein
und dann kommen datei wieder zurück in
die schüssel die fertig vorher auch ein
und dann dafür abgedeckt an einem warmen
ort etwa eine stunde gehen sobald das
herz aufgegangen ist stellt ihr die
brötchen her und ich zeige euch jetzt
einmal eine variante wie ihr sie
ungefüllt machen könnt und einmal eine
variante mit einer käse füllung ich
nehme dazu weichkäse vom türkischen
laden
ihr könnt aber auch den feta käse aus
dem supermarkt nehmen und ihr könnt
einfach für euch selbst entscheiden was
euch besser schmeckt ich finde beide
varianten ganz gut
ihr könnt sie natürlich auch mit
hackfleisch füllen oder mit einer
kartoffel füllung das werde ich dann
später irgendwann noch mal in einem
anderen video machen
heute zeige ich euch jetzt aber nur die
zwei beispiele so sieht der teig dann
aus wenn er sich verdoppelt
zudem schüttet jetzt einfach auf eure
arbeitsfläche gibt aber vorher etwas öl
drauf sonst klebt es alles fest
ich nenne es mal nur die hälfte
und den teil der decke pitter ab und
ständig zur seite
ich mag es ganz gern wenn meine brötchen
alle gleich groß sind deswegen wie ich
die jetzt vorher kurz ab und die sollten
zu etwa 70 gramm haben ihr könnt sie
auch kleineren oder größe machen
es bleibt euch überlassen heute möchte
ich etwas größere brötchen
der teig wird dann wieder rund gefahren
zu kugeln wieder alles von außen nach
innen
zeige ich erstmal die mit füllung wie
man die macht hätte deutsche hände jetzt
gut ein
dann medien dieses teilstück und drückt
mit den händen leicht auseinander
eine längere orale form
da habe ich jetzt diese krise den habe
ich satt volkert könnte auch petersilie
reim machen oder kräutern 71 ihr wollt
was er schmeckt
und da wird jetzt die eine seite
umgeklappt und die andere seite darüber
geklappt
die elbe ist jetzt gut andrücken
jetzt könnt ihr die frauen wie ihr
wollte sich nämlich das ende und es
wären wir das einmal herum oder 200 und
dann mache ich das irgendwie so ein
knoten von oben nach unten und legt dann
auf meine macht mich noch mal die
führung
zum treffer
dann wirbeln wie ihr wollt und dann von
unten
und jetzt noch die ohne füllung wieder
gute hände einfetten und dieses mal
drückte ich sie nicht platt sondern
zieht sie ein brite länger zu einer
rolle
und dass wirbeltiere wie es geht und
dann einfach
zu einem kreml formen
so etwas soll das dann aussehen wenn ihr
fertig seid also hier seht ihr ganz gut
die geführten brötchen und hier die
nicht gefunden
ich habe hier sechs groß und noch zwei
kleine also die zwei kleinen wiegen etwa
50 gramm jeweils die müsste jetzt an
einem warmen ort noch mal etwa 10 bis 15
minuten gehen lassen und danach werden
sie dann erst bestrichen werden die
brötchen ist nochmal aufgehen könnte
schon mal das eine vorbereiten
da kommt jetzt noch mal ein schuss milch
mit dazu und das wird schön miteinander
verquickt werden wir danach die ist
jetzt schon jetzt schön aufgegangen
hier ist einst auch wirklich aufgegangen
das könne da eigentlich wieder so
drunter stopfen
und da kommt jetzt diese eigelb milch
mischung
dieses bestreichen dürft ihr auf keinen
fall fordern gehen lassen machen weil
dann platzen eure brötchen auf beim
aufgehen weil dieses zeige dir dann die
oberfläche bindet und hebt so ihr könnt
jetzt zu lassen wenn ihr wollt oder eben
streut sie noch mit schwarzkümmel so wie
ich oder mit sesam oder anderen könnern
was ihr wollt was ihr da habt aber mit
diesen schwachen wir zahlte bislang tür
geschafft und so werden sie jetzt bei
200 grad etwa 25 bis 30 minuten gepasst
nach dem backen sie in die brötchen dann
so aus ihr seht sie haben jetzt deutlich
an volumen zugenommen sind schon
aufgegangen
natürlich kommt das dann auch durch
dieses backpulver was noch zugesetzt
wird
und hier seht ihr auch diese einzelnen
schichten und die kommen durch dieses
zwirbeln zustande
und das macht eben die lockerung dieses
gewächs aus
ich steckte es jetzt nochmal ab mit
einem tuch damit es auch schön weich
bleibt ich hoffe das rezept gefällt
deutschen macht die brötchen ab ich
wünsche euch viel spaß dabei und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal